the glass way you use for your cocktail  plays a huge role in not only the look  of your cocktail but taste and aroma now  this is the coins glass made famous  because of the Tom Collins cocktail  perfect for any carbonated drink it's  thin and has a small opening at the top  as he encapsulates all those bubbles for  your cocktail  nobody wants a flat gin and tonic the  next class is a martini glass beautiful  looking but also the fact that you hold  it by the stem it means you're not going  to change the temperature of the  cocktail now our last glass is a rocks  glass this glass is used to serve spirit  forward cocktails with the Collins where  you had all the carbonation entrapped we  want all those aromas to escape whiskey  drinks and a groan is classic cocktail  have always been served this way there's  a number of different cocktail glasses  you can use but if you have these in  your kitchen you're off to a great start  there's more cocktail videos like this  on the GQ Channel